[Music]
it is my pleasure
to welcome to yang speaks a person i
admire and have learned a great deal
from one of the most prominent
anti-corruption activists in the united
states today the co-founder and ceo of
represent us josh silver josh welcome to
the podcast thanks andrew it's good to
be here
now again such a fan of yours uh you've
been beating this drum since before it
was cool
i'm curious as to how the heck you got
so
inflamed and passionate about corruption
in the government back when we thought
still uh things still worked okay
i don't know if that's accurate well you
know it's funny there's there's this guy
randy keeler who inspired inspired
daniel ellsberg to turn over the
pentagon papers when he was uh when
randy was a 19 year old talking about
his opposition to the vietnam war
at yale
and uh he inspired ellsberg to to spill
the beans and randy told me in the 1990s
he said and this is going to date me
is that you know he's like it's all
about money and politics and our broken
democracy and if until you fix that you
can't fix anything it doesn't matter
if it's environment climate health care
poverty whatever issue education it's
all stuck or moving backwards or just
sub-par because the incentives are so
broken
because bribery has been legalized in
america that was in the 90s it's gotten
a lot worse with citizens united
but what's clear is you've got this
two-headed monster that is american
structural political failure that
thankfully you're writing about in your
new book and that's exciting
but that's you've got the media which is
failing particularly with the increase
in digital media the uh the sort of
information bubbles wait wait wait wait
wait josh the the media is failing
yeah
confirmation bias the manipulation of
the digital platforms the failure of the
major platforms like facebook twitter to
actually put
push back effectively and quickly
uh the failure of legislators to
regulate those entities as effectively
as we're starting to see in the european
union and then on the flip side of that
you've got the the second head of the
monster which is the failure of our
democratic systems elections ethics
campaign finance laws that have been
manipulated eviscerated
to actually incentivize extremism to
incentivize a lack of competition and
incentivize a lack of integrity and so
once you have that light bulb moment
that the structures themselves the
information environment and the
democratic system itself are skewed
towards negative outcomes
then you realize my god
why would i work on anything else
because until we fix this we can't fix
anything
you are right uh again you came to this
before me and a lot of other folks so
back in the 90s again to date you a
little bit that me that puts you
somewhere in your early 30s so draw us a
scene
[Laughter]
like what the heck were you up to in
your early 30s because the fact that you
started this very very significant
organization represent us and anyone
listening to this or watching this if
you don't know it represent us check it
out it's an incredible
uh organization that is trying to
improve our governance in various ways
it's non-partisan it gets people of
every political stripe
um but
uh how did you
become the sort of person who could
start such a significant org uh
starting back in the 30s and this wasn't
the first org you started i think you
started another org
yeah yeah
so also i'm a little younger than you're
making me out to be andrew i was in my
late 20s back then in the 90s but um
there at the time there had been a
couple of successful major campaign
finance reform laws passed at the ballot
um most notably in in the state of maine
another one passed in massachusetts but
was not enacted um there's some momentum
on campaign finance reform via ballot
initiatives i drove my chevy nova out to
arizona in 1997
and became the campaign manager of a
successful ballot initiative to create
publicly funded campaign finance uh
in in arizona that law went on the books
for about a dozen years
and then afterwards we saw some losses
in that space and i evaluated the
situation i talked to this guy robert
mcchesney a professor at the university
of illinois and and we determined that
there wasn't a lot of opportunity for
democracy reform at the time
but there was an opportunity to improve
the media reform environment and we
started an organization called free
press
that exists today and deals with
technology and media policy in the
public interest again so far ahead of
the curve because you did this back in
you know early 2000s 2002 2002 yeah a
little bit ahead either ahead of the
curve or just old i'm not sure which
andrew and then
and then after citizens united it was
very and that was 2000 january
2011 i believe 2010 excuse me
that was a major shift for the public
consciousness the supreme court rules
that any institution
unions corporations can give unlimited
money into american politics through
these so-called super pacs
and they said so long as it's
independent of the expenditures of the
actual candidate campaigns but that's a
gray zone that was never enforced so
it's this extra flood of money into
politics and suddenly the american
public was starting to finally truly
realize
just how toxic
and and dangerous this flood of money
into politics actually is
and that's when i had my light bulb
moment of you know we need to fix
democracy now that we have a critical
mass of people who understand the
problem and then i realized a couple
other things one is that all of the
organizations working in this space
were decided was about 10 years ago
decidedly progressive which is fine
but 75 percent of americans even more at
the time but 75 percent of americans
today
do not self-identify as liberal
further only 25 percent of americans
yeah no yeah you should probably stop
there for a second
listening to this i'm like what
but um yeah three-quarters of americans
don't self-identify as a liberal um and
i guess you'd throw progressive in the
same bucket so a lot of people listening
to this are in environments where the
concentration is much higher than that
where you think
um you know significantly more than one
in four uh friends of a lot of the
people listening to this are probably
self-identified liberals um so back in
2010 you said wait there are a lot of
non-uh self-identified liberals that
would also care about this issue
yeah and there's no organizations or
that are try advocating for fixing
american democracy for the 75
it's about right now it's about uh 35 of
americans self-identify as moderate 35
as conservative 25
as as liberal or progressive and then
five percent other so there's nobody
talking to that 75 percent that was
assumption number five is the yang gang
i'm just kidding yeah yeah
that is that is absolutely true and then
and then of course uh you had the
situation where you know only 25 percent
of americans are democrats 25 percent
are republicans and a full 50 according
to the most recent gallup data are
independents so we are we have to talk
to them because there's plenty of groups
talking to the left and further we have
to do most of our fighting on this issue
in the states the same way that the
suffragettes did it the marijuana
advocates the marriage equality
advocates it's stuck in washington let's
take the fight to the states and we
started just working on passing high
impact democracy reform laws at the
state and local level over the last 10
years and that's where what we've been
doing to get us to today
well it seems like you're the right
man for the job given that back in 97
you actually stewarded a successful
ballot initiative in arizona i feel like
you know like you got a taste for it
you're like wow we can just make this
happen on the ground in the states uh
and that's what represent us is trying
to
accomplish in
cities and states around the country
yeah and there's been over over 130
cities and states have passed either
binding laws or non-binding resolutions
on democracy reform in the last six
years since 2015 but this includes some
biggies like five major
anti-gerrymandering laws passed via
ballot initiative
in 2018 alone before that there were
only two states that had overdone that
era california in 2008 in arizona in
2010 we've seen as i mentioned earlier
ranked choice voting in open primaries
passed in alaska last year in the state
of maine twice um and a whole slew of
other reform victories around the
country and those
those campaigns
needed and this is what we do is we we
need they need support they need in-kind
professional uh drafting of the law
helping with political strategy and
campaigns
money
uh and and making sure that the
campaigns that are are the best and have
the best chance of being winning and
being implemented are those are the ones
that rise to the top and happen so this
is a critical part of this democracy
reform equation and what's really
important about it for your listeners
yang gang
is surely somewhat cynical because we
are seeing so much of a mess in american
politics today it feels like
opportunities actually fix the system
are scarce but this is an area where
there's actually cause for some optimism
[Music]
whether you realize it or not
you're likely way more creative than you
think
and in a world where we're all
sort of
geared towards being a little more
science
than art i think it's important to bring
out your creative side which is why we
chose to have skillshare as one of our
sponsors on this podcast because they
help you bring out your creative side so
you can take a class to learn to be more
creative in a whole bunch of different
areas right now this is ridiculous but
it's pretty cool i'm taking a class
on indoor gardening and how to grow
house plants because frankly
my new york city apartment could use a
little more
energy yeah that's probably good way to
put it anyway you can take classes on
how to edit youtube videos or how to do
portrait photography or how to do video
on instagram there's a ton of different
things whether it's a hobby or a side
hustle or just a way you want to learn
to do more things skillshare is pretty
freaking awesome and it's incredibly
affordable especially when compared to
pricey in-person classes or workshops an
annual subscription is less than ten
dollars a month so right now i want to
explore your creativity with
skillshare.com
yang so go to skillshare.com and get one
month free trial of a premium membership
that's one month of a premium membership
at
skillshare.com yang become a little more
creative better yourself skillshare.com
yang
[Music]
i i do want to retrace back to your
personal history uh because a lot of
people listening to this are
probably thinking how the heck does
someone become
someone like josh who winds up doing
this for a living uh starting a
successful org so you grew up on the
east coast right uh did you grow up
around political activists i think your
your mom was like a writer or a poet is
that correct yeah she's a poet and she
was she was an activist uh and i had
people like that guy randy killer who i
mentioned who was my neighbor who
inspired dan ellsberg so there was
definitely a bastion
of activists where i grew up they tended
to be progressive
um but
yeah that was an inspiration another
part of my story that you might have
heard is you know when i was 26 so
before arizona
um i was in south america on this epic
adventure and we were me and a buddy
were ambushed and he was shot and killed
and i was sort of shot and left for dead
and that was a very transformative
period in my life where i sort of
realized that life is short that i have
a little bit of time to do big things on
this earth and that i should make the
most of my time and energy and i think
one of the biggest takeaways i'm sure
one of the inspirations for your new
book is realizing like let's
take on these issues using the most
leverage we possibly can and when you
realize that structural reform political
reform is the way to do that there's no
going back
you do have this
kind of mildly super human energy and
aura to you that i i think a near-death
experience might have given you in your
video i mean i i've read the story
and if anyone uh wants to read the story
it's
uh horrifying and it seems like a movie
uh come to life or like a tv episode
but josh's friend was killed and josh
was left for dead and then josh made it
out uh and then he came back and he's
been this world-changing activist since
certainly this is not an experience that
anyone can replicate i was hoping he
might do something that
it's like oh here's some of the things
that i'd
uh you know
pursued to develop but you came back you
ran this ballot initiative you started
this org
and
one of the things i love about you is
that you you have a very firm read of
the problem but your very very solutions
oriented you're very very practical
and that's something that distinguishes
your org because your org is all about
the nuts and bolts
now represent us has a very very high
bar though you've enlisted some of the
most prominent storytellers in the world
to help with this which is trying to get
people excited about the plumbing
you know i mean like it's a lot easier
for me to excite you about
the
issue of the day
that the
political back and forth
but it's harder to get someone excited
about the mechanics and this is a
challenge that i personally am going to
be
uh experiencing myself
over the next number of
uh weeks and months um with my new book
because i agree with you that without
structural reform we're stuck
uh and so you've spent now uh almost a
decade maybe more now
trying to get people excited about the
plumbing
uh what are the lessons you learn and
when i talk about the high level
storytellers it's people like jennifer
lawrence and adam mckay and like these
hollywood types that you've
persuaded of the truth of the matter
which is that structural reform is where
to start
yeah well first of all you know one of
the challenges it it it is true i mean
you're the first person to ever say the
plumbing actually andrew but it's funny
because yeah i like it you invite
somebody over to your house and you're
saying uh you know rather than look at
the beautiful flowers and this this
incredible five thousand dollar new
couch uh and this widescreen tv i want
to tell you about why the the pipes in
my wall and the electric cables are so
important it is a little akin to that
but as you can tell just by the nature
of this interview that your listeners
have spent now less than 15 minutes but
you do need about five minutes to hear
the story and understand how this works
right like to understand like wait a
minute how is it that gerrymandering is
actually more of an extremism problem
than a competition problem right because
we all think of gerrymandering it's like
oh yeah that's when
partisan politicians prevent competition
and keep it a monopoly in their district
but actually
what it really does is push all the
the competition for congress
congressional races out of the general
election and to
the primary election where only about 17
percent of the voters on average
participate in their highly extreme
partisan voters and you create a
structural incentive to be extreme for
politicians because the only competitive
threat to them is when they're getting
so-called primary from the extremes of
their party in the primary so
you know once you ex have the moment to
explain that and people say oh my god
no i'm kidding
you can't get back basic background
tricks on guns it's like gerrymandering
as much as anything
uh once you have that aha moment that's
the aha moment jennifer lawrence
orlando bloom katy perry adam mckay ed
helms and the long list of other
celebrities michael douglas that that
work with us they've had that and it's
starting to domino right and i think
your new book is going to be helpful in
continuing to to speed up that domino
effect because in many ways i do think
that the future of our of our country
our democracy
hinges on how quickly we're able to wake
up both the masses and the influential
classes to this problem and instead of
actually fixing it yeah i i agree and
this is going to be my my new mission
and i do want to unpack what you just
said because it is so important
so
uh
17 percent of
uh voters participate in the party
primary in a
typical congressional election
and 83 of the races are either going to
be very clearly democratic or clearly
republican so if you think alabama
whoever wins a republic primary is going
to win uh for the democrats would be you
know whoever wins in
um like an urban area in um
let's call it detroit michigan like it's
going to be a democrat so if the person
wins the primary then they win
and who participates in the primary
number one the members of that party
but number two the most activated
members of that party about 17
and there's a very famous quote by a guy
named uh boss tweed who's of new york
politics and he said um you can do the
electing as long as i get to do the
nominating
and so
the average voter doesn't really have a
meaningful choice because by the time it
gets to the general
it's predetermined it's one of the
reasons why so many people are so
checked out on politics
generally another number that i cited in
the book um is that the overall approval
rating for congress right now is about
28 which is actually a little bit up
from what it was it was more like 17 not
that long ago like you know some people
are getting more excited about it
but it's still really low i mean 28 like
you wouldn't see that movie
but the re-election rate for the average
representative is 92
94
right uh and so if you're that average
representative to keep your job your
goal is just to keep
yourself from getting primaried and
challenged by someone who's going to
appeal to the most extreme 17 of voters
in your district
and then if you're presented with a
situation that might require compromise
with the other party you're going to
avoid it because you're like well if i
do this the uh
extreme 17 are going to be really mad at
me they're going to
have someone challenge me as being
impure ideologically
so i'd rather do nothing rather than
compromise because then i can't be
attacked
if i just hew to the party line
and the most prominent example of this
that's going on right now is senator
lisa murkowski of alaska who
actually flouted trump and said hey no i
think that uh the interaction's a
problem and you know trump didn't win
some other things that are heresy among
republican primary voters
her approval rating among
republican
alaskans right now is something like 15
percent
like very very low
but she
can still win
because alaska recently adopted open
primaries and so she can make her case
directly to all voters instead of just
the republican 17
exactly and we're starting to see it in
real time she's the only republican
co-sponsor of the john lewis voting
rights act
[Music]
real talk how is your mental health if
it's like mine probably not that great
i'm losing my mind postcode getting a
little better and the reason i'm getting
better is because of our sponsor
betterhelp which is
amazing secure
and well frankly fairly priced
counseling done securely online so
you can start communication and get
paired with
a licensed professional
on a safe private online environment
that's super convenient within 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online you can talk to
your counselor anytime you get timely
and thoughtful responses i love my
counselor it's freaking awesome and you
can get advice on depression or anger or
stress or family complex whatever you're
going through
better help is freaking awesome and it's
confidential convenient professional
affordable all the things you need done
conveniently online so i want you to
start living a happier life today and as
a listener you're going to get 10 off
your first month by visiting our sponsor
betterhelp.com
yang so join over 1 million people
taking charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelp help.com
yang
[Music]
i'm i'm gonna do something out of a
little out of character i want to turn
the interview to you for a second you'll
probably want to turn the same question
back to me but you know there's been
this
major shift in american politics over
the last few years where
a majority of the republican i say this
as a truly non-partisan organization and
an independent of myself as a voter
a majority of the republican party has
gone kind of full
almost like russian style autocratic
where they want to just sort of rig the
rules in their favor blatantly
and prevent competition and prevent
participation from voters who they think
are not going to vote for them
it has changed the calculus
strategically for much
of of us what us political reformers do
what do you
how profound do you think that impact is
andrew
well it certainly makes it harder to try
and uh present bipartisanship as the
answer or be even handed if one side
seems like they're trying to rig the
rules right in the left um the the thing
that i'm
uh mindful of is that
uh if you have an independent actor like
lisa murkowski who last i checked is
still a republican
um that that it just
goes back again to the incentives
problem it's like you have people who
are trying to rig it because they think
that's going to be good for them and
their self-interest
uh
that we have to uh try and change the
incentives uh for the people involved
and line it up with
um
more of the american public because i
think the people that are doing the
rigging that you're describing tend to
be hyper partisan
and and they may control the party in
certain places
but i don't think they represent
you know a majority of voters in any
area they might they might represent a
majority of hyper partisans in an area
so so so to me
uh this makes your work uh i'm going to
call it our work because i'm going to be
joining you in this um
all the more vital like we need to hurry
it up so you've been running an
organization now doing great work for
like a decade um
uh and then there's a feeling that the
ground is uh shifting underneath our
feet like you're that things are not
going well really like we're not winning
it seems like the democratic
institutions are disintegrating in real
time and we're looking around being like
wow voter suppression laws like that you
know that's not very
that's not very
uh patriotic of you or you know or
principal w
um and so it requires us to think bigger
about what kind of changes we need to be
fighting for i think
um
would you agree
i do and i think there are some changes
long term that we need to look at much
more
seriously like like multi-member
districts
which is another policy that would have
a profound impact for example it would
actually
end the gerrymandering debate
immediately if you had multi-member
districts because it's a completely
different way so
for example just so people who don't
know what it is in my state of
massachusetts we have nine members of
congress from massachusetts they're
actually all they're all democrats there
is quite a bit of gerrymandering in my
state um in a in a multi-member district
set up you would probably split the
state of massachusetts in half
and you'd have two districts one with
that would send two mega districts one
mega district would send four members of
congress to washington and the other
mega district would send five and then
in the election
all of the all of the the primary
election all of the um candidates are
exceeding the general they're all on the
same docket
and uh you just simply pick the one that
you want the most out of
all these many candidates for congress
and then the top four or five vote
getters out of that entire pool they all
go so what you end up having is you have
a decidedly conservative member go
you have a decidedly uh liberal one you
probably have a latino
candidate who goes a black candidate who
goes what have you but it's like a
it's a superior system and it gets us
closer to the the benefits of a
parliamentary system in a federalist uh
environment
now so is this the case that the uh fair
representation act is making which is an
act that that i believe has some
sponsors now in congress yeah no chance
of passing anytime soon but it's the
right idea and when we've seen this this
the proposal introduced via ballot
initiative in select cities around the
country
it has almost won several times so
it's actually something that's got a
shot it's just complicated and
technocratic now if we could back the
lens out a little bit for a moment um
well i just want to i just wanted to to
to talk about the merrep act a little
bit more josh sure um if i'm one of the
nine members of congress of
massachusetts does this not essentially
eliminate my
job oh currently
you would i mean if you're one of the
members uh today
you're actually
in a pretty good position because you
have name recognition and so
you could you could win in the mega
free-for-all yeah i guess that's
nothing to preclude you from doing it
the but the the opponents of this policy
just like with ranked choice voting are
the two major political parties right
because they currently enjoy a duopoly
you of all people know that more than
anybody and so
multi-member districts like ranked
choice voting are a direct threat to it
ranked choice voting is literally
preferred by everyone in this country
virtually
other than the most rabid partisans in
the same and you could say the same
thing for gerrymandering same thing for
multi-member district the things that
would actually really fix things
are despised by the partisan supporters
of the republican and democratic parties
now and again uh it's one reason i'm so
excited about your work is that there
almost needs to be a party for
non-partisans
which is i think sort of what represents
us
um
is the the beginning of
um i i and i love the fact that you got
these high-level celebrities to lend
their energies to it um because it's
such like a principled
populist case that everyone should be
able to get behind um and
uh you know and a lot of politicians i
think are sorry a lot of celebrities are
somewhat reluctant to touch politics
um so it you know it's a tremendous sign
plus they all have buddies all the
celebrities know each other
andrew it's practical i mean you know
jennifer lawrence for example
she is from kentucky and she's from a
really conservative republican family
and part of the reason she got behind
this is she was like you know what i was
tired of the us versus them and i wanted
to get behind an issue where i can say
you know this really truly isn't about
whether you're a democrat or republican
or liberal or conservative this is an
american issue
and everybody should be if they're not
supporting these structural reforms
because there's nothing partisan about
it this is just simply about
representation democratic representation
which is at the dna level
of our of our of our constitution now
certainly the constitution was drafted
imperfectly but it's made a lot of
improvements including the voting rights
act in 1964
and you know this is just
part and parcel of the legacy of
american democracy that's 244 years old
and it's the longest running democracy
in the world so
you know that that's no small thing at
the same time we're showing our age
though unfortunately josh
it is and it's also not considered a
full democracy anymore i don't know if
you've probably seen starting about four
years ago
international rankings by the economist
magazine
took the united states out of the
category of a full democracy and it's
there's only about 18 of those left in
the entire world and we are now
considered a partial democracy because
our democratic institutions are so
beaten down and broken
wow did they throw us in the oligarchy
category
it's terrifying no we're like down there
with like turkey i mean it's i don't
think we're that low but it's it's bad
it's it's it's really bad and it's
because
uh i you know it's not and it's not just
trump right it's that like trump
definitely
notched us even lower but this happened
um you know before trump and and it's
it's been just getting worse now if i
can pull out the lens the lens back a
little bit for your listeners
i think it's important to note like you
know in the in the fight to reclaim the
soul of american democracy i would argue
there's sort of three major fronts that
need to occur simultaneously
one is you know we need to continue to
build this movement and if you go to
represent.us you can see this can sign
up and be part of this but like we need
millions and millions of people who
understand have the light bulb moment
understand they try and get us the
millions john yeah and the book's gonna
help books can help and then number two
you need to keep doing what the
suffragettes and marijuana advocates and
marriage equality people did which is
just keep passing laws at the city and
state level
opportunistically
where
you just pass laws that could change
things that are right for that area and
you're not too dogmatic about it has to
be ranked choice voting it has to be
anti-gerryman you just
pass good laws wherever and whenever you
can
and we have to keep doing that
and then the third area
is particularly more important now is
you have to stop bad things from
happening like these
30 uh voter suppression bills that have
passed in 18 states in the last seven
months this is a big problem
and we have to continue to beat back
against voter suppression we have to
beat back the massive gerrymanderings
that are actually you know the census
data went to the states in august of
this year
and now the states are setting about
gerrymandering in a more extreme fashion
than they have ever because it happens
every 10 years it's happening this year
the super computing powers are better
than ever and especially states like
north carolina florida texas it's out of
hand i mean the democrats could have
some really really weird-shaped voting
districts they're they're going to be
like
they're going to like follow like
particular
neighborhoods around it's going to be
totally bizarre
big data fueled gerrymandering 2021 stop
that andrew like there's ways to at
least mitigate it you can't stop it but
gerrymandering is deeply unpopular and
you can name and shame these legislators
and public officials and at least beat
them back to some degree so you got to
play defense on these voter suppression
gerrymandering and other attacks on
democracy
while you're doing the good proactive
long-term work
[Music]
are you staring at your screen too long
probably is it ruining your eyes
probably that's why we recommend felix
gray blue light glasses they're the blue
light glasses that started it all five
years ago they realized our eyes were
not meant to look at screens all day and
they designed glasses that look really
cool and make daily screen time more
comfortable and the workday more
productive they filter 15x more of the
most important blue light to help your
eyes and frankly they look really cool
you can go online do the augmented
reality thing on their website and see
what you look like before you buy these
things i got the jemison
whiskey tortoise glasses
i need to bring them on the podcast
maybe i'll do an episode while wearing
them they're pretty freaking awesome so
check them out and you can go to
felixgrayglasses.com
yang check these out put on a pair of
augmented reality felix gray glasses see
how you look in them and with summer in
full swing you want those times that you
have to plug in to not crush your eyes
if you're gonna let anything crush your
eyes better be sunlight and not screen
light to put it that way so now
non-prescription and prescription
glasses are available check them out now
at felixsgrayglasses.com
yang that's felix gray f-e-l-i-x-g-r-a-y
glasses.com
yang you get free shipping free returns
free exchanges felix
slash
grayglasses.com
[Music]
are there local
initiatives that you can call out for
people that happen to reside in those
areas that you're excited about right
now
yeah so there are some exciting things
underway uh utah may be moving forward
um with a with an open primary ranked
choice voting it's possible not we don't
know yet missouri is looking closely
arkansas oklahoma
um there's massachusetts might revisit
this they tried last year and yeah let's
talk about this for a second josh so the
states you just named as well as maine
and alaska
are red states
um and yet most people associate rank
choice voting with
progressives
and massachusetts was one of the only
states that actually had it on the
ballot
this past november and it lost uh what's
up with that
it's kind of a wonky answer andrew so
the the real answer is
that
there's this what's called ballot
language and so if you're in a state
about 20 roughly half the states have
ballot initiatives half don't ballot
initiatives are increasingly under
attack and difficult to pass
but when you go to vote yes or no on a
ballot initiative you read what's called
the ballot language and it says do you
want to vote yes or no to a law that
would do blank
and the problem with with rank choice
voting is that a technocrat in the
attorney general's office writes that
and
that's not a bad thing it's just reality
and they tend to write literally what
the law does in the case of rank choice
voting it's like you're just a regular
joe you just dropped your kid off at
soccer you're late you're tired you
haven't had dinner and it's like this
law shall make it so that i can rank my
candidates in a sequence of three
and if one person doesn't get more than
50 of the vote then your last place vote
will instantly be applied
and people just gloss over and are like
i don't know i'm confused this makes no
sense no
and that's a fundamental challenge which
and it's the reason why massachusetts
lost and it would have required
a 20 or 30 million dollar persuasion
campaign and while 10 or 12 million was
spent which is a lot of money it wasn't
enough to beat that dynamic
wow
uh
is there a way to improve that language
or is it just the case that the attorney
general is going to write it and as the
attorney general just risk averse or is
there self-interest where they're like i
kind of don't want this thing to pass so
i'm going to make it confusing sometimes
that's the case it wasn't the case in
massachusetts in massachusetts the
attorney general here is actually quite
friendly towards these kinds of reforms
the problem is is that the short answer
is no you don't have sufficient control
over that because you know it they
literally the the law says
that the attorney general's office has
to make a description of the law put it
on the ballot and voters decide and it
suddenly becomes very political and
tricky if you alter it so
it's just an inherent obstacle and this
is one of the many that we have and
that's why we're not going to see these
kinds of reforms pass
until we
plumbing man it's back to the plumbing
back to your book it's like building a
giant number of people who are keenly
aware of this
and like you know getting 20 of
americans to actually know what's going
on here which is a lot
but it's doable and it would be a game
changer because if we did if we could
get one out of five americans to have
the light bulb moment hopefully you're
having right now listening to this
podcast well then we can actually win
these things yeah amen
so if massachusetts got it on the ballot
in november of last year does that mean
it's going to be on the ballot again in
22
no it means it's dead and there's gonna
have to be a whole new signature drive a
whole new effort um so there's a lot of
work to do the other but the so i and
whether that happens or not is anybody's
guess there's also an increased use of
legislative lobbying like so for example
a quiet important victory
this year the vermont state legislature
passed what we call colorado style vote
by mail which is a 100 vote by mail
system every voter gets a ballot
and uh it comes with postage and it goes
to a system where three out of the five
highest voter participation states in
the 2020 election where washington
oregon and colorado that all have 100
vote by mail systems it's contrary to
what former president trump says it's
secure it's reliable
it's proven it's convenient
and if we had that everywhere it would
be a complete game changer it just
passed in the state of vermont so we're
going to see more efforts like that in
other states around the country via
legislative lobbying so as i said before
we just have to keep chipping away at it
so we we referenced earlier how
both you and i are gravely concerned
about
the
ongoing erosion slash disintegration
of our
democratic
institutions and infrastructure a lot of
americans are in
a lot of doubt and you talked about how
a lot of people listening to this are
probably quite cynical
there was a lot of blaming of trump for
the last number of years and now that
trump's
out of the white house
now i think people are trying to figure
out who or what to blame
i
feel like
i feel like you've been making the right
case uh
over this last period
um
people are concerned though and it feels
like some of these local victories even
if we get them
um may not be
like an antidote to some of the things
that that ail us
how has your thinking shifted if at all
over the last number of years and again
one thing i love about you is that
you're a true
clear-eyed problem solver where you look
at it i mean for me
in my case i ran an entrepreneurship
nonprofit that i'd started uh and
ran it for six years
and
realized that the changes
i needed to
make
if i was actually going to solve the
problem were like much bigger than
uh what my nonprofit was going to be
able to actually deliver in a particular
period of time and then that's what
drove me to do something very rash which
was run for president of the united
states and at the time no one thought
that was a good idea
but it was bored of the fact that i'd
been
deeply invested in work trying to create
opportunities for americans for
years prior
in your case you're now you know again
the chief
anti-corruption pro-democracy activist
maybe
in our society you've seen it all you've
seen the wins you've seen the losses
um and it does seem like unfortunately
we're backsliding in various ways if i
were to give you a magic wand like what
would you do with it that might be so
number one it sounds like is somehow get
20 of americans to think the way you and
i do and i'm going to do my best to try
and increase that percentage i don't
know what it is right now maybe let me
start there for you like what percentage
of americans do you think get how uh
deeply problematic our
structures are and want to change them
between three and five percent
all right and that's because of you if
not for you it'd be you know it's
roughly the same amount that you've been
getting in uh
as a as a vote tally and you're in
love
you know okay it's the yang gang it is
the guy it's true
uh you know i i saw paul just for your
edification too josh that was um
it was
uh like my level of support
and it was in that range let's call it i
think it was like you know somewhere
like five to uh seven percent among
democrats yeah and then it rose to maybe
twice that level among like the general
public
[Laughter]
so there was there was something one one
of the things i did realize over time is
that i'm kind of a funny fit for
the democratic primary electorate
in part because i think the democratic
electorate
is more
invested in and also more
uh
likely to believe in institutions uh
like one of the numbers that i
uh i found very telling
is that 69 of democrats believe in media
that the media is telling the truth most
all the time
uh that number among republicans is
something like 19
and then among independents like folks
like you um it's like 38
so the so democrats like believe in the
in in what the media is saying they
believe in institutions they believe in
the machine
and then a guy like andrew yang comes
along and then like i'm not i'm clearly
not of the
[Laughter]
who's their establishment so there's
like some natural resistance and then
that resistance actually disappears when
i wind up talking to
uh
independents or republicans to a
significant measure
yeah i mean
for sure it's an it's an issue but but
you know you preface that
apt comment by by asking like if you
could wave a magic wand
i i think in in in the parallel between
your frustration after six years of
running a non-profit and running for
president i think the analog here today
is i do think that we the public
interest community
we need to start sharpening our knives
metaphorically and but but but hitting
the bad guys a lot harder like a lot
harder and creating much more political
pain and when i say bad guys i'm talking
about the tech platforms that i'm
talking about the facebooks and the
twitters
and the and the major purveyors of of
digital i mean you know the
misinformation the latest one around the
pandemic and kovid and vaccines which
they're finding despite
i'm air quoting here if you don't see me
best efforts by mark zuckerberg and
company to curate contact and content
and ensure factual accuracy there's just
gobs of disinformation flooding
facebook and other platforms we have to
beat those digital platforms back much
harder
we have to beat back
the autocrats and they do happen to be
republicans but it is not about
democrats republicans it's not partisan
but these folks who are trying to you
know decertify election results and
suppress votes
this is deeply on american behavior it's
it's what you'd expect to find in in
vladimir putin's russia
and we need to go after these guys
ruthlessly relentlessly in an electoral
sense and and get and make sure they get
unelected so do it smartly go for the
ones that actually are not so
gerrymandered that they're untouchable
but we have to start creating real
electoral pain in a very focused way on
the biggest threats to american
democracy
well i certainly agree with you on the
tech platform front
media has problems uh social media has
bigger problems
where social media
uh ends up rewarding the most
inflammatory
uh content i think there was one study
that showed that fake news spreads more
powerfully
than real news six to one on social
media and so if you're trying to make a
name for yourself the more
sensationalist your statement uh the
more likely you are to grow
and i think that's making it
so that
meaningful reform becomes next to
impossible because people can't agree on
even the basics
uh there's something
uh did you read
um ezra klein's book why we're polarized
it came out i think maybe a year and a
half ago i did
yeah so uh the argument he makes that i
think is really powerful
and it's something that i took to heart
um was that at this point politics has
become tribal in american life
uh and i discovered a new tribe through
my presidential campaign thank you yang
yang love you um but like the the
language i was using uh was just the
language of facts and figures around
economics and automation
uh and
it was wild josh because people did not
know what to do with it like like people
in the political world were like
this stuff uh you know was so foreign to
me like talking about the loss of four
million manufacturing jobs or forty 000
manufacturing jobs in iowa or or the
death of retail like these were not
things that ever came up and i think
that if you take ezra's
uh
learning seriously which i did one thing
he said that really hit home and people
should
reflect on what this means is that the
correlation between your political
viewpoint and your policy viewpoints
is uh very low
[Laughter]
that
uh that because i say i'm i'm
conservative and then if i actually list
out a bunch of conservative policies
like my correlation with those policies
actually kind of low like i'm probably
gonna be pissed off at high drug prices
too i'm probably gonna be pissed off
like a bunch of stuff
um the the correlation on a statistical
level is only 0.25
um it would be one if it was uh perfect
and the thing is we all imagine that
it's close to one that you know but but
the truth is americans function in teams
at this point and not in white papers
um so i discovered a new tribe uh
through my presidential campaign that
responded to
uh economics and technology talk and
automation
and like that that's really what the
task ahead of us is in my view josh is
to build this new tribe
around a tribe of facts and truth and
anti-corruption strengthening democracy
social media does make that harder
because now even facts are
um you know increasingly disputed which
is a very dark thing
um
and
i do think that
you're going to need the tech platforms
to be at the table if you're going to
truly fix this and our government
not atypically now unfortunately is like
way way way behind the curve on those
issues um i'm a big fan of tim wu who's
part of this administration
who is very sophisticated in his
thinking um the average member of
congress i think is barking up the wrong
tree um if you looked at the tech
hearings like they were arguing about
issues that i thought missed the mark
um very significantly and so just
throwing in my
echoing uh the fact that if you were
talking about the tech platforms you're
right
yeah but a couple things one tim wu was
the chair of the board of my previous
non-profit so i'm i agree with you
wholeheartedly but
um one thing that gives me a little bit
of of optimism and i'm not trying to be
sort of you know saccharine optimistic
for your listeners i actually believe
there's a lot of bright spots another
one is
if you look at that rapidly expanding
percentage of independent voters that
gallup identifies we talked about it
earlier building a new tribe josh we got
to give them a flag
yeah and and you know a lot of people
listening will say yeah i get it they're
50 but of the 50 who identify as
independents
most of them and this is true reliably
vote with one major
but the fact that their independence
is a real opportunity for us because
that's just massive fertile ground not
only is that 50 percent much more
predisposed to joining this new tribe of
ours that's also fact-based by the way
he didn't mention that
but also
there are high percentages of
self-identified republicans and
democrats who are deeply unsatisfied
with their party so no
yeah
yeah it is fertile ground and that is
that is how this can all happen and
start to domino the way we need it to
and we only need 11 million americans to
join the tribe there was a study that
looked at successful political moment
movements historically in every country
around the world over the last hundred
years an extensive study that showed
that every
movement that had mobilized at least i
think it was three percent of the
population i need to re-look it up in in
our case it would work out to about 11
million americans they were all
successful it was the unifying trade
well that's great 11 million sounds very
doable that's going to be my new target
number i live on goals josh as i know
you do too it's the only way you've
gotten so much done yeah
if someone wants to support your work or
keep up with you uh is represent.us the
best place for them to go it is join us
um we you have a home would represent us
we are nonpartisan we're about real
solutions we're about reclaiming
democracy getting every issue unstuck
and we can't do it without 11 million
people so by all means join
represent us is the truth josh silver is
a class act and i can't wait to work
with you to build this tribe thank you
so much josh and again man i learned so
much from you
uh you've been fighting the good fight
for years and years now and we're going
to get you a lot of company
likewise thank you andrew good being on
[Music]
you